it's great to be joined today by Joe
McConnell who's a research professor at
the desert Research Institute in Reno
Nevada he's an expert in ice cores
studies of past climate and human
impacts on the environment and there's
no shortage really of different areas
where we could we could talk about ice
studies Joe but let's just generally
first of all talk to us about what types
of information about the past can we
glean from studying ice yeah so well
first thanks for having me on and
secondly so so yeah we emit all around
us are little particles and droplets in
the air and those droplets get blown
around the earth and deposited through
precipitation or onto the ice sheets and
glaciers around the world and so we can
go back by by drilling into an ice sheet
we can go back and study the chemistry
of the atmosphere the study and study
the chemistry of precipitation and go
back you know hundreds of you decades or
hundreds of years or thousands or even
hundreds of thousands of years and that
can tell us a lot of things about
climate you know sea ice and things like
that about forest fires about volcanoes
and then in this particular case about
anthropogenic impacts or pollution so
how can we determine when a time wise a
portion of an ice core is from in other
words is there some equivalent to like
rings on a tree to determine age or how
would we know that yeah it's a great
question the the so depends on the ice
score in this particular study that
we've we've done in Greenland recently
the annual layers meaning the amount of
snow that falls each year is about let's
say eight inches of snow eight inches of
water equivalent so about let's say
thirty inches of snow is one year at the
surface and and essentially all the
things that we measure in the ice core
have a seasonal variation so it's just
like exactly actually say it's like a
tree ring in the sense that we can count
annual layers so we start at the surface
when we drilled the ice core and then we
just go backwards in time counting one
you
two years three years four years in this
case all the way back to about 1100 BC
so about 3100 years long is that about
the limit to which ice can be useful in
figuring out elements of what was going
on in history timewise about 1100 BC
well you know it's an interesting
question they you can in theory of
course you can go much back much further
we have ice core records that we
annually layer counted in my group as
far back as thirty thousand years in
Antarctica in terms of the human impacts
we'd like to go back to say four or five
or six thousand years before present you
know so maybe three or three to five
thousand years BC but the problem is the
quality of the ice so this may be a
little more than you want to hear and in
Greenland for instance which you drill
these ice cores on the ice sheet divide
and that's where we ideally would like
to drill them at about out of about 1500
BC or 1200 BC that time that corresponds
in that time you enter something called
the brittle ice zone and that's where
the ice is so over-pressured and the
glacier that as soon as you bring it to
the service it explodes are nearly
explodes and it cracks and fractures
like crazy and so the reason we chose
the depths we did in this ice core whose
because we wanted to get to the very top
liver lies go as far as we could into
the glacier and still get really good
samples what can't ice core studies tell
us that maybe at one point we thought
could I mean obviously they're not going
to be able to predict the results of
sporting events so I don't mean like a
full list of what we can't glean from
ice cores but in the sort of universe of
the types of data that maybe we would
like to or thought we might be able to
get from ice what does it turn out we
really can't learn from ice cores well
so so one thing to keep in mind is we're
a long way from the source and
princesses in Greenland or Antarctica
where the best ice cores come from
you're a long way from the things that
you're likely to want to study so you
can understand resolution whether
there's transport of that pollutant to
to the ice sheet a good example of
something we hope to get and
so far haven't been able to get out is
copper pollution from these ancient
economies in Mediterranean and the
reason is because there's so much there
are other sources of copper things like
volcanoes forest fires content 'old us
things like that that are blowing around
in the atmosphere and that creates a
background noise level if you will a
background variability and to see a
something like economic signal we need
that signal to be above the background
sufficiently that we can say absolutely
that's humans that are causing that lead
is a nice example because let has very
low background levels in the natural
environment but the pollution signal was
quite large and so that's why we were
able to use lead in this particular case
yeah so let's now talk about lead and
this idea of being able to make
deductions about what was going on
economically based on that and
specifically you've been looking at the
the Roman economy so let's get sort of
into this a little bit what was the role
of lead in that economy such that it
would even be interesting to look at
yeah so there are a number of reasons
I guess chief among them is that silver
ores and the Romans ran their economy
Earl especially during the Empire and
the Republic ran on silver largely and
that's what they made their coinage from
the Denarius and so they needed to have
new just like when the US was on the
gold standard or the silver standard we
needed to have supplies of new metal
coming in for our coinage and so the way
the Romans got that was by mining lead
silver ores and so when they wanted the
silver they would smelt and collate and
so forth the ores and in the process in
order to get the silver in the process
they would release a lot of lead the
atmosphere you know they were I'm not I
don't mean to say they weren't
interested in lead but lead was not
their primary objective it was in the
silver we think that was the primary
objective so you can imagine that the
supply of new metal into the economy is
a very good indicator of the strength of
that economy because the economy relies
on that new metal so generally speaking
the idea is that there would be sort of
a correlation between the we might call
it like production or G
P of ancient Rome that we could deduce
from the amount of lead that has that
appears in the ice cores that you study
is it more or less that type of
correlation yeah I think it's probably I
mean so we're using it as a now in our
world we would say a proxy of economic
activity I'll economic activity and the
reason that's true besides this new
metal idea is that in order to mine and
smelt light or LED silver ores at this
level of scale now you need to have a
lot of governmental organization you
needed to have slaves unfortunately to
do the mining you needed to have the
ability to D water mine so logistical it
was a pretty big deal and required a lot
of organization you can imagine a lot of
government services and organization an
army and so forth to to be able to do
this production at this level and so you
know when when things were going well
that those logistic logistical resources
you might say fell apart a little bit
and that's why we we think this is a
good indicator another reason why we
think this is a good indicator of the
overall economy have the results from
studying the ice confirmed or changed
our understanding of how the Roman
economy was doing at different points in
time well it's interesting because you
know as an ice core guy the I wasn't
that aware of what the historians were
doing with the data prior to a few years
ago and these colleagues these ancient
historians and historians or economic
historians contacted me about this but
it turns out that there were 18
a total of 18 points over this same
three thousand year period roughly that
had been measured before eighteen points
over 3,000 years with each point
representing two years and this was done
in the 1990s again using a Greenland ice
core and historian it's a lack of other
information we're using those eighteen
points to argue things like whether the
Roman Republic was a more efficient
economically or whether the Roman Empire
was more efficient economically yeah and
you can imagine political scientists had
discussed this and so forth for a long
time fine decades if not centuries
what they inferred from the previous 18
points was that the Roman Republic was
more efficient and in fact are much more
complete data instead of 18 points we
have nineteen twenty one thousand sorry
twenty one thousand points from that we
can very clearly see that the most
sustained and stable period of lead and
pollution and therefore the Roman
economy was during the Roman Empire and
so that's a fundamental difference in
historical understanding of what was
going on if we can I'd like to talk
about a couple other areas of ice
studies and some of them are relatively
topical we hear that in you know
corporate media the conventional wisdom
is that we are rapidly losing ice in
general on our planet we have also heard
what some call the sceptical position or
the climate science denying position
that there's actually an accumulation of
ice taking place at the poles both can't
be true right I mean this this is an
objectively knowable fact it sounds like
to me absolutely and and from a
scientific perspective from an
observational perspective there's no
question that ice is disappearing
there's no question that the planet is
warming up and driving that loss of ice
I mean absolutely no question you can
argue about things like sea ice because
the sea ice is sea ice and Antarctica
for instance is highly cyclical so in
I'm meaning there's a 20 to 30 year
period in the in the content of sea ice
around Antarctica and right now we
happen to be or at least in the last few
years we happen to be in a period where
sea ice in Antarctica was increasing but
again that sea ice not land ice sea ice
doesn't change sea level because it's
floating in water it doesn't change sea
level but land ice if you move water
from the land ice reservoir into the
ocean back into the ocean where
originally came from them then you'll
raise sea level so that's I think where
the confusion comes from and there's no
question that glaciers and ice sheets
the vast majority of them are rapidly
disappearing and I should add that
they're disappearing in a way that we
would predict meaning that climate our
understanding of climate science and
glaciology and so forth we would predict
the loss that what we're seeing
so it's perfectly consistent with the
observations are perfectly consistent
with global warming theory okay now as
far as indicators of the impact of
humans on our planet's climate that we
can see through ice one of the
criticisms of temperature records for
example direct temperature records that
we hear is that they go back to 1910
1920 1880 you know it's just not a lot
of time speaking in terms of the age of
our planet when it comes to ice what
kind of a window does ice give us both
quantitatively in terms of number of
years and you may have already answered
that when talking about you know a
couple thousand three or four thousand
years total and qualitatively about our
impact on the climate yeah so so yeah
observations as you mentioned
observations have gone back let's say
reasonably extensive observations have
gone back about a hundred years maybe
120 years something like that ice cores
can take us back I mean as far as
800,000 years that of course the
resolution that you get on the record is
very for 800,000 years ago but the kind
of thing that I study typically I mean I
do work on on old ice as well as young
ice but the whole not a second here the
age of the ice that that you were where
we would say we have put a pretty high
resolution high quality record I'm at at
least 120 hundred and forty thousand
years it depends on whether you're
talking about Antarctica or Greenland in
terms of temperature you know
temperature is one of those things is
still a little bit tough to get or to
understand from an ice core we typically
use water isotopes in combination with
measurements of actually the temperature
of the ice so you can imagine if you
have a piece of ice sitting there and
you from the air above it then slowly I
think Richard Ali my colleague at Penn
State uses the analogy of a turkey in
the oven and how I put a frozen turkey
in the and then the heat will propagate
into the frozen turkey and melt it over
time and that's kind of what we do in an
ice sheet is we you know when we measure
the temperature of the ice itself and
from that we can use models to tell us
what the temperature of the air above it
absolutely fascinating work out of
curiosity do you spend a lot of time in
cold places so that the ice remains ice
while you're studying it I mean is that
like a day-to-day thing about your job
yeah sure I do go to Antarctica and
Greenland and other places quite a bit
to collect ice cores particularly
earlier in my career and now I tend to
send my grad students for postdoc to
wherever and then also another one I've
another place I send my grad students to
post Docs is into the freezer here when
we're analyzing analyzing the ice we
typically are in the cold room about
minus 20 centigrade so about let's say
their degrees Fahrenheit more or less
and and spending all day and there's
pretty owners all right so like Boston
in January basically is what it does
what it sounds like
but for more time yeah Jo McConnell
research professor at a desert Research
Institute in Reno Nevada thank you so
much for talking to us about your work
today now thank you very much for the
interest